Rosie O'Donnell really really hates
Trump but I'm like most people in her
world who really hate Trump she can
credibly claim it's not a new thing
she's been hating Trump for many years
but she's no closer to winning that
debate yesterday and MSNBC Rosie showed
she still has not recovered from the
2016 election here's part of it we are
gonna write the ship there's no way that
he's gonna prevail because he's evil
he's dark it's the opposite of what
America stands for
I always thought why didn't they
counter-program his rallies cuz Nazi s
crowley when he was elected what I wrote
on Twitter was we should impose martial
law til we make sure that the Russians
weren't involved in the final tallies of
the votes to send the military to the
border so I would have sent the military
to the White House to get here martial
law Nicole Wallace thinks that's a good
idea
Dean Cain is an actor tonight you know
Dean you've been here all your life
obviously your famous actor if I were
running the Hollywood Chamber of
Commerce I would call Rosie O'Donnell
and say you pull back a little more shil
law really you're embarrassing us yeah
well I mean that thing was a joke she
said about sending the military over to
get him out of the White House yeah it
was a joke a thinly veiled joke but when
she did say you know she wanted she
tweeted martial art you know impose
martial law until we're sure the
Russians had nothing to do that was
insane I mean that's a coup well it is
insane it's crazy so what I mean but
don't other people in her world say look
Rosie I get it you don't like Trump
you're okay fine but you're discrediting
yourself and the rest of us by acting
like a mental patient on TV don't do
that
well that sounds entirely reasonable
talk early why would something like that
happen you know I know Rose yeah I knew
her back on her show yak in the day and
we were very friendly and wonderful I
don't know that she would talk to me now
but I I disagree with her yeah and I
would be happy to sit across her and say
I disagree I and even on that show all
they did was laugh and they're all the
same why didn't anybody offer a
dissenting opinion and say well that
doesn't make any sense
why don't Colossae really martial law I
think that because that's a little
miming right now so how often you hear
stuff like that here at dinner Monday
through Sunday
I just won't go to dinner so I'll miss
it that night so it's just it's
ubiquitous it's constant on every film
said I hear it all the time but here's
the funny thing I'll hear it from some
of the actors but then we'll go through
we're shooting something you know the
grip will give me a little bump like hey
I know that's such an interesting point
and I've knows this exact thing
how different are the political views of
the cruise that sometimes unionized
wage-earning cruise from those of the
celebrities working on them I would say
they're diametrically opposed that's
been my experience and I've only been
doing this for about 40 years
oh don't don't at some point say I'm
supposed to be on the side of the
average person the underdog I'm
surrounded by underdog people making a
hundredth of what I make but I hate them
for their views is there any dissonance
no they don't hear that know because
actors are you know we hear all we hear
is what we want to hear most of the time
I'm not really putting myself in that
camp because I am an actor but I'm you
know I'm a Princeton educated kid I I
travel the world I do things that I
think have some some some substance in
them I told the world leaders I'm in bad
places but a lot of these people they
you know you're cobbled as an actor so
and you're told you know oh you're so
great all the time that that people
start to believe it they start to
believe that their opinion means more
than the guy who's you know you know
clapping I mean if you're making ten
million dollars a year and denouncing
your cameraman as immoral maybe you
would get some soft organs or or at
least you know out-of-focus
yeah okay great to see you Tucker oh
thank you sir